مرحبا بكم الى هذه النشره الموجزه اعلنت
الخارجيه البريطانيه وقفه جميع الواردات
الغاز الطبيعي المساء من روسيا اعتبارا من
يوم امس وقالت الخارجيه البريطانيه انها
بهذا القرار تقطع عن رئيس الروسي احد
مصادر تمويل حربه في اوكرانيا داعيه دول
العالم الى خفض اعتمادها على الغاز الروسي
يوم امس تداول العمله الوطنيه في المناطق
التي ضمتها روسيا مؤخرا سيصبح الروبل
الروسيه العمله النقديه الوحيده في هذه
المناطق ويشمل القرار المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره موسكو من جمهوريه ايدونيسيا
قالت مديره صندوق النقد الدوليه
كريستالينا جورج ايفا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
تضرر بشده جراء الحرب في اوكرانيا واحضرت
من ان نصف دولي قد تدخل الركود الاقتصاديه
العام المقبل
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان صواريخها
الدقيقه بعيده المدى استهدفت اول امس
مصانع عسكريه اوكرانيه تستخدم لانتاج
المسيارات الهجوميه من جهتها قالت لاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في خيرسون ان القوات
الروسيه قصفت المقاطعه التي تقع جنوبيه
اوكرانيا نحو 40 مره خلال الساعات الماضيه
وان القصف الروسيه اسفر عن مقتل مدنيا
واصابه اخرين والحاق اضرار احد مستشفياته
المدينه
تعهد زعيم كوريا الشماليه
بزياده انتاج بلاده للرؤوس النوويه بشكل
كبير كما وجه اوامره بتصنيع نوع جديد من
الصواريخ البالستيه العابره للقارات جاءت
هذه الخطوات بعد ساعات من اطلاق
صاروخان قصيره ندى قبالته ساحلها الشرقي
ردنا على ذلك عقد كبار قاده الجيش الكوري
الجنوبيه
الكوريه الجنوبيه عن وزير الدفاع تحضيره
من ان بلاده لن تتردد في الرد بقوه على اي
استفزازات وحضرها من تقويه السلم في
المنطقه
نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان عن مصدر
حكومي قوله ان 14 شخصا قتلوا واصيب 18 في
تفجير انتحار عند المدخل الرئيسي للمطار
العسكري وسط العاصمه كابول ولما تعلن
ايوجها مسؤوليتها عن التفجير الذي قالت
مصادر امنيه انه انتحاري
افادت وسائل الاعلام الرسميه السوريه بان
عدوان اسرائيليا استهدف منطقه جنوب مدينه
دمشق ولما تتوفر تفاصيل عن اضرار المحتمله
او اصابته وكانت تلك المصادر الاعلاميه
ذكرت الندويا في جارات سمع في سمائل
العاصمه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]